♪ ♪ ♪
la créativité est une histoire
de famille. Pour une rare  une ,
père et fils ont accepté
d'exposer ensemble.
- On s'est fait souvent proposer
des prmble et je crois
qu'on est assez indépendants
aussi les deux puis moi, de mon
mon petit bout de chemin
par moi-mêmei-mêmei-mêmei-mêmei.
ARMAND VAILLANCOURT
- En dehors de : le père,
autre chose. Je pense que dans
Alexis a actuellement,
c'est irremplacable. Il a la
curiosité, il a l'énergie,
- L'exposition "Deux coeurs,
Deux têtes - entre rêve
et réalité" présente une
des deux artistes.
- On a quoi? 6o ans, 63 ans de
différence, fait que de créer
d'Armand qui vient complètement
d'une autre époque puis
moi qui viens du futur,
- Armand Vaillancourt est un
des précurseur de l'art militant
au Québec. Il a transmiss
communes et des objets
du quotidien comme matériaux
de base riches pour la création,
où il y avait,it direit direit e
une cour à scrap, mais en mêmeee
trésor. Fait quei, j'ai
grandi à travers ça, et ça te
des déchets, qui
habituellement, qui amènent duo,
puis quand tu les regardes
d'un autre oeil, bien il y a
des choses incroyables à faire
- Des matériaux qu'ils subliment
fortes qui poussent à la
ion. C'est ce qui a séduit
Diane Dufresne, une amie
DIANE DUFRESNE, artisted on regi
toutes les couleurs, toutes
les... C'est une expositiosition
coup de poing.- À 92 ans, Armant
ne s'est pas assagit, il garde
le feu sacré.travailler,
on travaille et puis je pensequi
fait mourrir, c'est juste
la mort. Moi, çans ma vie
d'avoir... de me sentir que :
"Ah! Bien là, je suis assez
vieux faudrait que j'arrête."
Bien n
mon tarbinouche!
- "DeuDeux têtes -
entre rêve et réalité" estu Cent
e Repentigny.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,